good afternoon first I want to thank
Special Counsel robert muller for his
service to our nation over the past two
years mr. Muller and his team of
prosecutors and investigators worked
tirelessly to follow the facts and
pursue justice to the farthest extent
allowed although Department of Justice
policy prevented the Special Counsel
from bringing criminal charges against
the president the special counsel has
clearly demonstrated that President
Trump is lying he is lying about the
special counsels findings lying about
the testimony of key witnesses in the
special counsels report and above all
lying and saying that the special
counsel found no obstruction and no
collusion in his statement this morning
special counsel Muller reaffirmed his
report it found substantial evidence
that Russia attacked our political
system that the Trump campaign benefited
from Russian interference that Trump and
those around him repeatedly welcomed
Russia's support and that throughout the
subsequent investigation Trump sought to
obstruct Muller time and time again
special counsel Muller
today repeated three central points
which are critical for the American
people one the special counsel did not
exonerate the President of the United
States of obstruction of justice -
obstruction of justice of which special
counsel mullah found substantial
evidence is a serious crime that strikes
at the core of our justice system 3 the
Constitution points to Congress to take
action to hold the president accountable
for his misconduct
unfortunately special counsel mullet was
unable to pursue criminal charges
against the president because Department
of Justice policy prevents a sitting
president from being prosecuted
that policy in my opinion is wrong but
it prevented the Special Counsel from
pursuing justice to the fullest extent
possible
therefore as Muller again highlighted
this morning
it falls to Congress to respond to the
crimes lies and other wrongdoing of
President Trump we will do so make no
mistake no one not even the President of
the United States is above the law
congressman's went forward with
impeachment proceedings and given what
Muller has said meaning that he feels as
though the report says all that he needs
to say will you then subpoena him to
testify in front of Congress with
respect to impeachment question at this
point well options are on the table and
nothing should be ruled out what special
counsel most said loud and clear today
to the American people is that President
Trump is lying when he says no collusion
no obstruction and that he was
exonerated
if Muller wanted to exonerate the
president from having committed a crime
he would have said so instead and he
says he would have said so instead the
special counsel makes clear that
obstruction of justice which he found
substantial evidence out is a serious
crime that strikes at the core of our
justice system and that the Constitution
points to Congress to take action to
hold the president accountable that's
exactly what we will do the president's
response to repeatedly lie to the
American people and ignore oil
congressional subpoenas is amaro and I'm
lawful no one is above the law and we
will hold the president accountable with
regards to impeachment will you then
move forward at a particular time you
say it's on the table but what exactly
does that mean
we are following through in our
investigation we will continue to do so
and we'll make decisions as they seem
indicated everyone
so a subpoena Moeller to to testify then
mr. Muller told us a lot of what we need
to hear today it's very important to be
clear on what he told us on what the
special trustee told the American people
he reaffirmed was in the investigation
which was in the report about the
investigation which found substantial
evidence that Russia attacked our
political system that the Trump campaign
benefited from Russia's interference the
Trump and those around him repeatedly
welcomed Russia's support and that
throughout the investigation Trump
sought to obstruct justice and undermine
Muller and the investigation over and
over again the president did the
investment sorry the special counsel did
not exonerate the president from having
a committed a crime
DOJ policy prevented Muller from
bringing criminal charges against the
president so the president is lying
about the special counsels findings
lying in saying that the special counsel
found no obstruction and no conclusion
and I should add the Attorney General is
lying about that too that is serious and
we will take action to hold the
president accountable for his misconduct
again I'll repeat no one not even the
president is above the law